[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends and
a happy Mother's Day to all of the moms
out there would you like to hear an
amazing fact
Connie Tanaka is the oldest mother in
the world and the oldest living person
born January 2nd in 1903 in Fukuoka
Japan where she still resides Connie is
now age 117 years and 129 days she and
her husband Hadid O has four biological
children and adopted a fifth child
during World War two she worked in a
store selling hutong noodles with her
husband whom she married in 1922 after
hideo and her son died during the war
she continued working in the store
before retiring at the age of 63 at 114
she was still in good health and
occupied her time by playing the board
game Othello and taking short walks to
the senior facility hallway her other
hobbies include calligraphy and
calculations she credits her longevity
to family hope and lots of sleep
interviewed in 2018 she said she'd like
to live another five years and make it
to a hundred and twenty on March 9 2009
teen Kanye was recognized as the world's
oldest living person by Guinness World
Records you know very rarely in the
Bible does it give the age of women and
probably for good reason
stay with his friends we're gonna learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
welcome listening friends the Bible
answers live and if you have any Bible
questions then you're free to give us a
call we've got lines open we are live
not only are we on satellite radio
we're also streaming on Facebook and
social media and that would be on the
amazing facts Facebook page and not only
streaming the audio or streaming the
video if you want to take a peek at
what's happening here in this very
humble studio and we invite you to join
us with your questions calling with your
question now a great chance of getting
it on tonight's program that phone
number 804 six three seven two nine
seven with your Bible questions we don't
claim to have all the answers but we've
got some Bible programs and our Bibles
here at our fingertips we'll search
together one 800 phone number again
1-800-443-1999 remarkable to hear of
somebody that you know today you hear
about somebody who maybe it's a hundred
and maybe a hundred and five that's a
big deal but to pass the hundred and ten
mark 150 I had a church member that made
it to a hundred and eleven oh yeah
that's that's prayer is very rare and
yeah a hundred and seventeen sounds like
she's still alert and you know clear
thinking and that's really remarkable it
is yeah they I looked at a little video
they had online of when they were
celebrating her 117 birthday and she was
clapping along with them so it was kind
of astonishing to see hope she continues
along but you know in the Bible I
thought it was
interesting you can find the age of
virtually every patriarchy in the Bible
let me tell us Adam you know Seth Enoch
you know all the way where's he not
still alive
so he's the oldest and but I can only
think of maybe one woman in the Bible
where it tells her age and that was in
connection with the miracle of Sarah
having a baby at 90 and I think she died
in a hundred and twenty if I'm not
mistaken hundred in 27 I believe I
wasn't yea Genesis 22 I looked it up
before the program Genesis 23 verse 1 as
curious yep 127 years but can you think
of another woman in the Bible where it
gives her age well we spoke about it
before the program the closest that we
could think of was Anna in the temple it
didn't give us her exact age but says
she was serving in the temple for 80
years yeah and you know we guessing if
she started that maybe around the age of
20 she's close to a hundred but the
Bible doesn't say for sure exactly so I
think there's a lesson in life that you
just don't ask a woman water ages that's
right you folks were expecting some big
profound biblical truth but we had to
find something special for Mother's Day
there are some interesting mothers you
know revelation actually has two mothers
she had one mother is not a good mother
she's called the mother of harlots and
revelation 17 but in Revelation 12
you've got a wonderful beautiful mother
who is the mother of the church you
might say and through her the Messiah
comes and she's called the Bride of
Christ some have wondered if the woman
in Revelation 12 is Mary because she
gives birth to Jesus but no it's really
speaking of the church that was to bring
forth Christ to the world and we have a
lesson that talks about that that
explains it all in prophecy and we would
like our friends out there to be blessed
free version of that today yes it's the
one of the amazing facts study guides
and it's called the Bride of Christ and
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks the phone line to
call if you'd like to receive the study
guide he's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line as for the study
guide called the bride
of Christ that's 808 three five six
seven four seven and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven again that's 800 four six
three seven two nine seven we do have
some phone lines open this is a good
time to give us a call we'd also like to
greet all of those joining us on
Facebook across the country around the
world on the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page also on the amazing facts Facebook
page and if you're watching on Facebook
you'll see the phone number is right
there on the screen one eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven with
your Bible question all right I think
there are we ready to go to the phones
we do we got wrong listening in
Tennessee Ron welcome to the program
good evening thank you for waiting
Mike mm-hmm my question is blessed
number of your programs dealing with
what happens when we die and admissions
sleep and my question is
I'd like some scriptural references for
where and what sleep all right well when
you go to John chapter 11 and Jesus says
our friend Lazarus is asleep when the
Bible talks about a person sleeping and
death it's it's just basically saying
it's using that metaphor of sleep it's
not that they're you know taking a nap
under the ground anywhere it's using the
metaphor of sleep to simply say that
they're waiting for the resurrection to
have God you know download the essence
of who they are in their glorified
bodies and so what do you think it's
talking about when when Jesus said
Lazarus sleeps or King David slept or
Stephen slept and the others in the
Bible the dead in Christ who are
sleeping will rise what my research
shows me that there tells me that it's
the soul that sleeps and when I looked
up and looked it up it was saying and
basically in the Old Testament
in Hebrew Sheol and reference for that
is Jonah when he was in the belly of the
fish at the bottom of the ocean that he
equates being dead in a sense within in
the belly of Sheol which is in the heart
of the earth which is the same thing as
Hades in the New Testament and when I
looked him up in Strong's exhaustive
concordance in the different definitions
for that is it's the holding place for
the souls that so the departed souls yes
so when you think of a soul what do you
think that looks like it doesn't look
like anything it's it doesn't have any
appearance just like the spirit doesn't
have an appearance it's not exactly
visible right so the way I understand it
and you know we're talking of course
about things that are probably over our
heads a little bit because you're
dealing in a spiritual realm as you said
I think what a person dies first of all
if you want to find out when a person
dies you just put creation in Reverse if
you go back to creation in Genesis you
see where God breathed into Adam the
breath of life that's the spirit of life
combined with the the body which
included the brain where he did all his
thinking he became a living soul
the combination of the two makes a soul
when a person dies it says the spirit
the breath of life returns to God who
gave it
the body returns to the earth dust the
dust ashes to ashes that person really
ceases to be a soul until they're
reunited at the resurrection so the
person is not a soul but yeah but the
soul still exists because there's
another one I think in 2nd Peter chapter
2 I think it is that it says that
Jesus's soul was not left in Hades right
well yeah of course Christ Hades is the
grave there and Christ was not left in
the grave he rose Oh have you but it's
supposed to be the heart of the earth
and a grave isn't in the heart of the
earth and like I said I looked up the
definition of Hades and
sisty place the holding place for the
departed soul do you think that a soul
is conscious in death no okay well we're
on the same page have you looked at our
study yeah but it still exists how jesus
also said dunno and you read this yeah I
was watching one of your specials and it
said that do not fear Him who can kill
the body but cannot kill the soul now
that's the first death Matthew chapter
10 it's still exist after the body dies
and the spirit goes back to God
yeah I don't believe that I don't
believe that a person ceases to exist as
long as you know even though Abraham
Isaac and Jacob are dead
jesus said God is not the god of the
dead he's a God of the living and so I
believe that people still exist after
death I don't believe they're conscious
and it sounds like we're on the same
page there and you know kind of the way
I look at it is I might download my
computer information from one computer
to another it doesn't do anything when
it's sitting on a USB Drive but the
information is saved and God knows who
we are and he downloads us into a new
body at the resurrection
there's no consciousness of death so if
you haven't seen it already wrong or
anyone else out there if you want the
free study guide on what the Bible says
about our the dead really dead we will
be happy to send that to you it's got
lots of Scripture again the number to
call if you'd like to receive that he's
eight hundred eight thirty five six
seven four seven you can just ask for
the study guide it's called other dead
ready dead we'll send that to anyone who
calls and asks and I think you'll find
it interesting I'm actually looking at a
copy of it right now pastor Doug and
there's a lot of Bible verses dealing
with the subject and answering a lot of
questions so just a great resource
thank you Ron we're gonna try and get
some other callers here we probably a
recent are listening from North Carolina
recently welcome to the program
[Music]
and it was on Matthew 25:31 through 34 I
think it was and I mean you did a great
job explaining this when and it just
they're saying it again for those who
didn't hear when Christ comes back
basically what is saying he's not
talking about what he did for you he's
talking about and this is the judgment
he's talking about what you did for him
a lot of people like to say it doesn't
matter if we do this we do that but in
Matthew 25 31 through 34 of you will
read it it does matter yeah this is
talking about when in the great judgment
Jesus returns and he separates he's as
the parable he separates the sheep from
the goats the Sheep represents the save
the goats represent the lost and then he
asks six questions and he said he
basically makes a declaration of six
things he said I was hungry and you fed
me I was thirsty and you gave me drink I
was a stranger you took me and I was
naked and you clothed me I was sick or
in prison and you came to me and
basically Christ is saying this is an
unusual parable because instead of
Christ talking about sins of commission
where you commit a sin he's talking
about sins of omission where we neglect
to care about anyone around us and
you're right you know they are rewarded
they don't even know they're serving the
Lord they're just loving their neighbor
and Jesus said in as much as you did it
to the least of these you did it to me
he tells the righteous enter into life
eternal and the the others may go away
into punishment because they did not
care about their fellow man and so yeah
that is a great parable and and it's not
just you know I might add reason or that
Jesus isn't just saying I was hungry and
you gave me food it's I'm hungry and you
gave me the bread of life I was thirsty
you gave me the living water I was naked
and you gave me the robe of
righteousness so there's an espiritual
analogy for each one of these things as
well and thanks for the promotion if
anyone wants to they can probably see
the Good Samaritan sermon where I think
I include this and maybe Pastor Ross too
that'll be on YouTube again if you'd
like to receive our study guide talking
about the law of God it's called written
in stone and
between the law and grace will be happy
to say Amen to anyone who asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
asked for the study guide called written
in stone again that's 800 eight three
five six seven four seven
we've got Darrell listening from Florida
there or under the program hello
Pastor John Ross and Doug Batchelor
wanting to know if you guys could
explain
Daniel 70 weeks to me you know I'm gonna
let pastor Ross take a stab at this so
we could both do it but I'm wondering if
he can do it quicker than me because
it's a you're talking about a you know
chapter 9 if it's a big prophecy yeah I
mean the key area I think when talking
about the 70 weeks you're finding Dan
chapter 9 and starts really in verse 24
where it says seventy weeks are
determined upon thy people and upon the
holy city to finish transgression make
an end of sins to make a reconciliation
for iniquity to bring in everlasting
righteousness to seal up the vision the
prophecy in to anoint the most holy
so there are a number of things that's
reference here within this 70 week
prophecy one prophetic day is equal to
one literal year you got seventy weeks
or four hundred and ninety days there
were 360 days in a Hebrew year so you're
talking about a total time period of 490
literal years a time period that was
given especially to the Jews that was
their probationary time period during
that time period they were to welcome
the Messiah talks about the anointing or
the most holy I was talking about Christ
when he was anointed and his baptism in
27 ad the starting point for that
seventy weeks is with the decree to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem and you
can read about that in verse 25 know
therefore and understand that from the
going forth of the commandment to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem we know
that to be a desert seas the decree was
given in 457 BC and sin Israel chapter
seven and you have the actual decree in
Ezra chapter 7 and starting the 457 BC
going forward in time 490 years you end
on the date 34 AD and that of course the
stoning of Stephen also the conversion
of Paul or Saul to Paul
the gospel then going out to the Gentile
world so there's so many other things
part of that Sydney weed prophecy but a
lesson we do have a lesson on that right
on time I think is what it's called of
course that time puff is very
significant because it also speaks at
the time of the coming of the Messiah
when he was to be anointed in 27 ad
three-and-a-half years into that a
Christ would die not for himself he died
a sacrifice and then another 300 another
three-and-a-half years where the
Apostles preached primarily to the Jews
and then we have 34 a B and a closing of
probationary time for Israel as a nation
not individuals but as a nation so
that's just a quick overview Darrell on
the 70 weeks oh thank you yeah you did a
good job and again we want to remind
anyone wanting to learn more about this
and as you said it's really a
fascinating great study take a look at
the study guide called right on time and
it deals with the 70 week prophecy of
Daniel chapter 9 we're looking now at
our next caller is calling
internationally and we're not sure who
the person is we just did Richard I
think from Guyana
all right showing up on yours yeah okay
Richard yes well not too clear so god
state your question and then we may put
you on mute while we answer that is a
good question you know we had that we
had that little dilemma in our church is
your church gives away food we're of the
belief that you know pork is still
considered unclean biblically and you
know we a bunch of agencies donate food
to us and we then distribute it to the
poor this was back at
another church I pastored and they
donated among the other things they gave
they gave a bunch of sliced ham fresh
you know sliced ham for sandwiches and
we can all look to each other and
there's all these poor people lining up
we thought what are we doing some were
saying well we can't give that out
another is saying they're gonna go eat
it somewhere else it'll fill them up and
and when back and forth on that one so
that's a great question so what would
you do no we decided to do you know our
people they made the sandwiches I don't
know I felt they're good about it but
they said you know these people are
hungry don't throw it away give him give
him the food and as long as they know
what it is
they probably either time so it was
basically it was given to us by someone
else for the expectation we would give
it to hungry people so we felt we needed
to do that but yeah I just you know
you're it's like I used to smoke pot and
I used to grow pot and when I finally
decided I don't want to do this anymore
I would I pulled up my pot list I want
everyone to know this over 40 years ago
so go easy on me I pulled up my pot
plants and gave them to a friend after
what I thought if I thought that was bad
for me why did I give it to my friend
it's not helping him at all so I
wouldn't do that with alcohol well you
know what's something like what I've
heard of in the past what people have
done is you know if you do receive food
and even if they themselves might not
eat that food maybe it's clean meat for
example chicken or something and and yet
they can they can provide that for
somebody else who wouldn't have an issue
eating that they do that but I I think
when it comes to like you said alcohol
or tobacco you don't want to give a
mixed standard to that person I think
there was a law in in and we have to
look it up you might find it that if if
a beast died that was not slain they
could give it to the Gentiles right but
they were not to eat it and so I think
that was the argument that ended up
being used at our particular church but
yeah that's what they call a moral
conundrum if you're in a lifeboat and
you've only got so much room in the
lifeboat who do you let in the lifeboat
if there are too many people in the
water so you know it's one of those
things I'd love to ask you the
University philosophy class
thank you Richard from my georgetown
guyana we appreciate your calling in
from across the ocean
all right the next color that we have
let's see if mines working here we got
Nana listening from North Caroline is
that correct Nana yes yes welcome to the
program thank you very much good evening
pastor Doug I have a question for you
guys and my question is actually coming
from Exodus chapter 25 yeah and then I
verse 21 and 22 is about a sanctuary if
you look at this verse God is speaking
to Moses saying I put a mercy seat on
top of the AK and then it continued and
at 22 he says and I will meet with you
and I will speak with you from above the
mercy seat between the two mature but we
shall test now my questioning is down
there he also says that then you will
communicate the same information to the
children of Israel does that mean that
Moses was going into the century to
speak to God or was it Aaron so what was
the purpose of Aaron and then being
consecrated as well to to minister in
the in the century
or was it Moses going in and getting a
message and speaking good yeah good good
question
normally this would only be the high
priest that would go into the Holy of
Holies and communicate to the Lord and I
should just mention that you have a
vision in Isaiah chapter 8 where Isaiah
sees the Lord on his throne the real
throne between the two cherubim and so
the ark was you know symbol of that but
Moses had a unique role in that he also
served at as high priest you know right
now we got a unique situation in in
history where you've actually had two
popes that are alive and that doesn't
happen too often but you know maybe that
was a bad comparison anyway
Moses and Aaron were both brothers Moses
was definitely the prophet called of God
he went in to initially consecrate the
sanctuary but he would go into the Holy
of Holies and speak directly with the
Lord and then Moses I think was only
Aaron was supposed to only go in on the
day of atonement well you know we got
that verse in Exodus chapter 33 verse 11
where it says so the Lord spoke to
Moses face to face face as a man speaks
to his friend now that wouldn't be for
everyone that was a special relationship
that Moses had with God and Moses of
course was the law giver and so God
would communicate to Moses he's will
Moses who then communicate that with the
people that didn't always happen in the
case of a priest
often you find that there was a prophet
and a priest active at the same time
whereas Moses was both prophet and
priest although he didn't function in
the capacity of a high priest yeah that
very rarely and of course when Moses got
the 10 commandments no man was allowed
to go up on the mountain not even its
brother right he had a face-to-face
encounter up there with God you do have
that Samuel who is also a prophet and a
priest I'm sorry go ahead no honey no no
I mean are they are they at a prophet
that came after Moses they they will go
into the most holy place also to speak
to God no I think he's the only one that
we can think of that serve
contemporaneously with a priest that
could go in at a will Moses went in you
know not just the day of atonement but
whenever God communed with him he went
in before the Lord he didn't speak
through the veil Moses went right into
the presence of God so it was a unique
relationship yeah yeah without that
thank you good question next caller that
we have is let's see David listening
from New Jersey David we've got about
two minutes before the break yeah thank
you yes my question is a two-part do you
believe in predestination and tend we
know if we are one of the selected all
right well that is a good question and
that is probably one of the most deeply
debated to question by good Christians
I mean Calvin and Luther and Wesley all
disagreed on on this subject of
predestination
no God has desired his predetermined
that he wants all men to be saved and
it's in Timothy where God who would have
all men be saved but that does not mean
that God arbitrarily is deciding who is
saved he knows we do have a choice and
that's the whole idea of the freewill so
some people interpret predestination to
mean that God's decided you know he's up
there in the sky and he's kind of
eeny meeny miny moe I think I'll save
these people and I won't save the others
and the people on earth who might be a
lost that would like to be saved have no
choice in it
God is not doing that God would have all
men to be saved and it tells us in
second Peter 3 God is not willing that
any should perish and then of course
John 3:16 whosoever believes in Him
might not perish so the salvation is
available to everyone that's why we send
missionaries out
I mean if God's decided who saved well I
send a missionary mm-hmm he'll work it
out that was the attitude of some
Christians for years but because some
people will not be saved if they do not
hear he god uses humans to bring them
the message you know we do have a book
in the last few minutes or moments here
before I break and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
is simply called can a saved man choose
to be lost can I save man choose to be
lost or and deals with this subject the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and assets eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven
thank you David a great question that
the truth is a Christian can have a
sense of security about the relationship
with the Lord but we must not assume
that once we're safe we can't be lost
and live recklessly and so there is a
great balance between the two don't go
away friends as you can hear we're
having our break music come up we're
gonna be back taking more Bible
questions some lines open give us a call
be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers seek his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 thank you for taking my
call pastor Doug Pastor John been
listening for many years
Thank You dr. Doug question is mostly
for you since I've heard you say so many
times on in sermons that you would like
to be the first pastor in space so you
got connections what would be your
advice to how to witness to someone who
genuinely believes that the earth is
flat this is not on it's it's not
they're not joking when they say it is
whoa I know quotes Bible verses like
Genesis 1:6 what is this firmament and
First Samuel to a about The Pillars of
the Earth and and I know what I want to
say but I don't want to be offensive
because I care about this person I care
about their heart and I care about their
salvation and they genuinely believe
this and they they say things like well
you can't believe what science says look
at evolution and the moon landing was
faked in it how do you witness to
someone who who is so caught up in all
of this but that you can't get through
to them with with um with Bible truth
yeah you know and I agree you need to be
loving there are some good people
believe it or not in in this day and age
where you know there are certain things
that I would think are self-evident
truths
and it is I believe a self-evident truth
that the earth is a sphere it is round
and that it hangs in space as a heavenly
body like the other spheres you know all
the information points that the the few
places you'd find in the Bible where it
uses metaphors to talk about the four
corners of the earth they even knew then
that the earth was not a big sheet with
four corners you know we use that
expression now to say that you know
someone went to the four corners of the
earth and we know it's a metaphor or
when we say the Sun sets we know the Sun
doesn't go down we know that the earth
is revolving but from our perspective it
looks that way and you know I know one
or two people that got caught up in this
and it's it's to me exhibit a of a
bizarre conspiracy and you know you need
to be loving and kind to people and
respect them you sometimes you just have
to respectfully disagree and when people
tell me they think the whole moon
landing I remember when I was a kid and
we saw the moon landing I was alive then
and we thought this is wonderful
and saw those you know flickering
black-and-white images come over our TV
I had a friend who said all that's all
fabricated my god that my pastor said
God was not gonna let them go to the
moon and this was all done in Hollywood
I thought for a minute you are you
serious
because what I know about human nature
is if two people know a secret it's not
a secret and it is just not possible
first of all they didn't have the the
film technology back in 69 to do the
special effects they're claiming we're
done
secondly it's not possible for that many
people to be involved on a conspiracy of
that scale every pilot who's flying
internationally they say is part of a
conspiracy they really actually know
that the world is flat I'm a pilot and
pastor Ross and I've flown around the
world many times in different directions
the world is round and I've flown all
the way around the world is so you know
GPS on the screen and I can look out the
window sure enough there's the polar cap
so you know it's just
they've got an answer for everything I
know what you're saying and I just you
almost have to see you know we just
respectfully disagree there's so much
evidence what do you say yeah absolutely
well thank you John I guess that's the
base we can we can offer you there that
is a challenging thing and you know that
actually even comes up from time to time
with people very seriously share
something with amazing facts and say
this is the truth that you need to
preach to the whole world that the world
is flat I mean this is Bible truth
unfortunately I think it's a distraction
of the devil yeah what in the world
aren't being accomplished by that why
would the world want to deceive us into
thinking the world was round if it's
really flat what would there be to gain
right so what a wasted conspiracy say
anyway so hope that helps a little John
but yeah it is it's a difficult subject
we've got another international caller
we got emmanuel calling from Ghana
Africa
Emmanuel you're on the air good morning
good morning please how you did good say
good morning to the rooster for us your
question please my question is in the
first Thessalonians chapter 4 verse 15
to 17 the Bible says the dead in Christ
will rise first and this cause half of
creditors in the air they're living and
then in witness in chapter 20 verse 15
he says that meant was that so I want to
know what that the dead meant was fed
before the dead in Christ will rise
first or the dead in Christ will rise
first before the dead man is said now
what was she talking about revelation 20
yet this refreshing twenty and then
twelve to fifteen okay and it says and I
saw the dead small and great stand
before God and the books were opened and
another book was opened and the dead
were judged according to their works
okay so when this is happening there is
a judgment that happens during the
Millennium is that what
you're understanding his pastor us and
of course this this final judgment the
heavy end in Revelation chapter 20 verse
12 we call this the great white throne
judgment and this really occurs at the
end of the 1,000 years when the New
Jerusalem comes to an you read about
that in chapter 21 and then all the
wicked are resurrected so those who are
resurrected in the first resurrection
are the righteous that occurs at the
second coming of Christ those who are
resurrected in the second resurrection
that's the wicked and that's the group
that's described you in Revelation 20
verse 12 I saw the dead small and great
standing before God so obviously they
were resurrected and it says they were
judged out of the book of life and then
verse 13 talks about how that the sea
gave up the dead that was in it and
death and the grave or Hades gave up the
dead and then finally it says verse 15
anyone not found written in the book of
life was cast into the lake of fire that
is the final judgment and destruction
that comes upon the wicked and you know
Emanuel just helped prove the fact our
previous caller was talking about how do
you respond to someone says the earth
was flat
here we are pastor died in California
and it's 7:30 8:00 in the evening and we
at Emanuel listening in Africa and we
know it's evening out time but there was
a roost in Africa that was telling us it
was morning and they don't lie so was
the other side of the world and then we
had a call before that from Guyana in
kind of fun to have the international
calls you by the way we never did tell
the previous caller about the earth
being flat there are verses like in job
in Isaiah where it says the circle of
the earth and he hangs the earth upon
nothing and so there are there are
scientific terms also that explain you
know what we understand about the earth
being the globe all right all right
thank you Emmanuel next color that we
have is Jayne listening in Savannah
Tennessee Jane welcome to the program
how long were the children of Israel
from the time they left Egypt to the
time that they went into Cana how long a
period of time was that well you've got
just a little more than 40 years from
the Exodus till Joshua led them in and
they still spend about five years
fighting wars before they began to
divide things up and what he called cast
lots for their inheritance so am i
answering your question yeah we were
anyway we had a you know quite a lengthy
thing we stopped here at our church and
read in the Bible and anyway yeah it was
about 40 no a good question
I think Joshua led them in what we would
call 1406 BC he led them across the
Jordan and they ended up fighting the
Battle of Jericho forty years before
that you have the Exodus where they
crossed the Red Sea and so there's you
know I think God tells us pretty plainly
that they wandered 40 years seems like
for about a year I could be wrong
exactly on the date but it seems like
within a year they left Egypt crossed
the Red Sea made it up to the Jordan of
the first time and the spies were sent
out right and then they came back well I
think they first went to Mount Sinai and
got the that's right Mount Sinai
sanctuary ten commands right then they
made it to the Jordan then the spies
went out and then they came back and
then God said because of my unbelief
you're gonna be 40 40 years in the
wilderness so don't work for a little
more than 40 yeah
whether it's 41 42 not exactly sure on
that
hope that helps Jane thanks so much
thanks you cold next politically heavies
k1 listening from Buffalo New York k1
walking with the program
hi are you doing great and now do you
you're having cold weather up there is
that right yeah we just had a little bit
of snow come down that's a little bit we
have 93 degrees here so the world is and
your question my question is how like
what does the Bible say about like human
enhancement such as biomechanics
replacing like missing limbs well I
don't know if there's any verse that
addresses that of course jesus healed
people that were handicapped in' they
walk I don't think there's any moral
dilemma if science provides a way for a
person to have a prosthetic arm or leg
or something like that I'd start
worrying if they start providing you
know brain cloning or something but as
long as it's you and you're operating
your extremities and praise the Lord for
medical advances that help that happen
so am i answering what you're asking
yeah I just didn't know a relation to
where they talk about how it helps when
it's like not cutting your body lights
not putting marks on your body oh yeah
well in the verse where it says you
shall not make cuttings in your flesh or
tattoo marks on your body
the pagans had a practice when they lost
a loved one they would cut their beards
off that's why it says do not Mar the
corners of your beard for the dead some
people think it's a Loggins shaving
because one place it doesn't say for the
dead but and they would cut their flesh
when they were mourning they might cut
off a finger when they were mourning uh
and then of course it says you know
don't make markings in your flesh
there's nothing wrong with having
surgery and there's nothing wrong with
you know surgery or something that might
help you to receive any kind of
prosthetic limb
I would think that'd be a great blessing
the Lord would approve of you know right
now pastor die both of us are wearing
glasses helps us see a little clearer
that's something that's being created to
enhance the ability for us to be able to
see that would be true of somebody that
gets a prosthetic leg or prosthetic arm
if it's gonna help them be more
independent or hearing aid there you go
now some resist that for a while but one
of those are thinking all right well
thanks for your call go on we appreciate
that
we got Susan listening in New York Susan
welcome to the program yes thanks for
taking my calls quick question going
back to Genesis 32 26 29 every time I
read this in my Bible study or or any
other place I'm kind of wondering
whether if I was already planned
God before it happened like a lot of
things that people say that it was only
was already planned this and this in
that it was already planned isn't he
think that certain things that happen in
the Bible talk about where Jacob
wrestled with the angel yes not the
angel he says well my version doesn't
say the angel he says that he was
covered and because he went he went back
across the river and he went back to
where he was camping it wasn't something
but it was something that he had there
and he found this man in that particular
place and then he fought him and then he
asked for the blessing how do you know
the inna we was God or why he asked for
the blessing or he said he's not gonna
leave until he's blessed well in the
property let me give the background for
this real quick Susan just so our
friends listening you and I know what
we're talking about this is an
experience where Jacob has he's he had
run away from the promised land because
he had stolen the birthright from Esau
and after living oh I think about 21
years in Haran
he married ended up with two wives and
two concubines had I think it was ten
children at that point coming back he
hears that Esau scumming
with 400 men - evidently kill him so
Jacob splits his family up to help him
be a little safer and he goes and he
prays and while he's praying it says he
ran into a man and Jacob thought it was
a man because he's praise afraid of his
brother coming to kill him and as he's
wrestling through the night this being
that he's wrestling with touches him and
dislocates his hip so he fights with
supernatural power and that is in verse
24 and once that happened
Jacob still doesn't let go he thinks oh
this is this is an angel of God or it's
God and later he says I've seen God face
to face so many believe that this was
what they call it christophany did Jesus
came to bless him and Jacob said I won't
let go and unless you
you know pastor like there's a cross
reference verse and Susan you might find
this interesting too in comment on this
you look up in the book hosea chapter 12
and verse 3 and 4 it actually says
speaking of Jacob it says yes he
struggled with the angel and his
strength he struggled with God so Hosea
is pretty clear that this angel capital
a is representing God it's priced the
angel of the Lord again we're not saying
that Jesus an angel the word angel just
means messenger right this messenger
that's come from heaven it's the
pre-incarnate the son of God so yeah
does that help a little bit Susan yeah I
was just one there Lula fine you know oh
my god he's all-knowing and all-powerful
and he's the creator no one you know I
think yeah I think the Lord let him do
this because Jacob was wrestling with
God in prayer for forgiveness for his
sin from years earlier that he would
protect his family and keep in mind God
did God had promised I'll be with you
and I'll bring you back again and he's
claiming that promise yeah and it seems
like when you read this in Genesis at
first Jacob didn't realized who this was
at first he thought probably it was
somebody sent by his brother to to kill
him and so he begins just wrestling for
his life but somewhere along the way he
begins to realize this is not just
another man there's something special
and then reads about how that later on
he says I won't let you go until you
bless me so here Jacob realizes that
there is a blessing from God in this
situation you know and something else
I'll just throw in for the interest of
our listeners is people know about the
the strength of David and the strength
of Samson but the Bible also says Jacob
was extraordinarily strong when he first
met Rachel he removed the stone lid from
this well by himself that normally
required many Shepherds to do it and
water the Sheep and so I think that it's
not that anyone could outwrestle God but
I think the Lord allowed him to wrestle
with him in prayer that he'd realized
his weakness but and what Jacob did is
in an
oh gee for us God let it happen to also
be a lesson for us sometimes God will
allow us to patiently wrestle with him
in prayer before we get the blessing so
don't give up praying too soon it says
he wrestled with them all night mm-hmm
I would get tired so I think there's a
lesson in there thank you very much
Susan for your question
we've got Katherine listening from my
Georgia cap dream welcome to the program
Thank You pastors I'm gonna ask that you
just bear with me and follow this train
of thought okay as I present the
question in the beginning we know that
God created Eve for Adam and he said
it's good it was not good for him to be
alone and Eve belonged to Adam and I'm
going to assume had you not entered the
world they would have been together even
to this day because God were dating them
to be together and then I go to the
Gospels where of course the Pharisees
are trying to trick Jesus and I want to
know the lady who will she be married to
in heaven because she had several
husbands and Jesus said to them that
they'll be no marriages in heaven and my
train of thought is God is love God
ordains for lack of a better word I
guess that love between a husband and a
wife that bond that's unlike anything
else and the next thing that we know
when we awaken from our sleeping death
is Christ but don't we carry with us the
love that we have from this earth and
I'm wondering if it's terminology we're
talking about in paradise in paradise
the word marriage may not be because I
don't remember it in Genesis but it's
just so hard for me to imagine that and
I know that's earthly terms but I don't
think God's gonna do some kind of magic
or well I know he's not going to do
magic
some miraculous thing to suddenly wipe
away all that love and all of those
memories just and it's going to be so
much better than what we've got here
none of that makes sense to me God's a
God of War I agree with you and I help
me right now I I agree first of all if
you look in first Corinthians 13 it
tells us that in the resurrection well
let me just read it to you in verse 12
now we see in a mirror dimly but then
face to face now we know in part but
then I will know even as I am known when
we get to heaven we're going to know
people we're gonna recognize them we're
gonna remember our Redemption and our
lives on earth now it is true
isaiah says you know as we go on through
eternity the former painful memories
will not come into mind but it doesn't
mean god brainwashes us and I don't
think that God is saying you know where
Jesus said they neither marry nor are
they given in marriage Christ is
answering a particular question they're
trying to create a conundrum for Jesus
about this woman who has seven husbands
who is she married to in the kingdom and
Jesus is saying you know there'll be no
new marriages and that doesn't mean that
God is going to hand Adam and Eve
divorce papers when they get to heaven
or that a married couple here cannot
enjoy each other's company and intimacy
in heaven they will not have procreation
as we do now cuz you know God told Adam
and Eve to you know reproduce and fill
the earth well the earth is gonna be
pretty well populated by the redeemed
and if everybody continues to procreate
you know we'd be spilling off the planet
and of course if it's flat God could
keep expanding the planet but otherwise
we just drop off but anyway so I I think
you're saying
the same thing that you know we are
still going to have a love and
relationships and know each other in
heaven and take our experiences from
this life and those loves into the next
world but there I don't believe there'll
be new marriages and I don't think
they'll be procreation and you know
there's a well I think Jesus actually
states that past that I get that - that
in verse 30 says in the resurrection
they neither marry nor are given in
marriage but I ask the Angels in
guarding as the angels of God in heaven
so we know angel
don't procreate and yet angels are very
intelligent beings they have special and
unique relationships amongst themselves
of course they have a relationship with
God and I think in heaven the redeemed
will continue to have those intimate
relationships with family that we had
you on this earth that will translate
into heaven and I think we'll get to
know new people in heaven too but as
said the the marriage relationship here
especially as far as growing a family
having children that that will not be
taking place according to this verse
yeah and there's one other verse that I
found a cross reference for in 1st John
3:2 the Apostle says beloved we are now
the children of God and it's not yet
been revealed what we shall be I think
there's still you know Paul says we
can't imagine what God's prepared for
those that love him nobody will be
disappointed and I think it's hard for
us to even comprehend the beauty of the
new world and the new earth so we just
need to take some things by faith I
think we're all gonna be surprised when
we get there let's just get there Oh
time for another question yes one more
we've got lotus listening from San
Bernardino California Lotus welcome to
the program hi how can we help you
tonight I'm reading the King James
Version and from Luke 16:19 through 23
and it doesn't seem to be parable it
seems that starts with there was a
certain rich man and I think from I've
said that it's a parable but I wanted to
do explain that little bit in depth yeah
as far as the main thing I was looking
at is verse 23 all right that's good
question lotus-eyed and let's take a
moment here and do our best to explain
it first of all it does begin by saying
there was a certain man but if we go to
the parable of the prodigal son
it starts the same
when Luke often starts the parables of
Jesus that way you look at the prodigal
son it says a certain man had two sons
but it's a parable and he also has a
parable of lost sheep in that same
chapter and a parable of a lost coin so
then when you get to Luke chapter 16
verse 19 some of the reasons we believe
that it's a parable is because the
people in heaven and hell heaven forbid
they're going to be able to talk to each
other
nowhere else in the bible does it say
that when a saved person dies they go to
Abraham's bosom that really represented
the the the hope of the Jew to be with
Abraham and then they've got the rich
man he goes to Hades that was the
punishment of the pagans they couldn't
go to the place of Pluto the God of
Hades and so Jesus is using powerful
metaphors here and just before you get
into the parable that starts in verse 19
if you go up a little bit more to verse
14 it kind of gives you the context it
says now the Pharisees who were lovers
of money also heard all these things and
they derided him speaking of Christ then
he jesus said to them you are those who
justify themselves before men but God
knows your heart for what he's highly
esteemed among men is an abomination in
the sight of God then he goes on a
little later and says well there was a
certain rich man clothed with purple and
fine linen and he describes them they
loved money they loved the esteem of
others and yet there was this beggar and
then of course the roles get exchanged
where the beggar is rewarded and the
rich man he suffers this torment and
what else I think pastor day is just key
here is the last part of that verse
verse 19 that talks about a resurrection
of Lazarus yeah
hey by the way we've got a book we'll
send your free copy Lotus the rich man
Lazarus had listening friends we took
this program to the end we're enjoying
it we don't want to quit so tune in next
week we'll do it again
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California terror attacks
natural disasters political instability
and global economic meltdown these are
the images people generally associate
with the tribulation and the day of the
Lord but did you know the Bible speaks
about another day of the Lord just
before the great Judgment Day amazingly
imprinted on the very fabric of time
itself is a 24-hour period called the
Sabbath that was meant to forever be a
time of restoration for every human
being a day the entire world is largely
forgotten you'll be surprised to learn
how this special day of the Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called
the last day of prophecy to order call
800 538 7 to 75 or visit a book store
calm
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com DG no amazing
facts has a free Bible school that you
can do from the comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at www.ge.com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]